un pasaporte de vacunación en el
teléfono parece un futuro distópico pero
pronto será una realidad en dinamarca
los daneses tendrán que mostrar los
suyos para ir al teatro al cine o para
salir a comer en europa islandia ya ha
comenzado a emitir certificados y suecia
dice que hará lo mismo reino unido lo
está pensando y grecia defiende que
impulsaría el turismo en francia la
opinión está dividida si se pudiera ver
si eso significa que la gente puede
volver a ser libre para aquellos que
quieren la vacuna creo que es una gran
idea
avn y de música pop yo estoy en contra
es inequitativo te autorizo
el pasaporte les permitiría reabrir a
muchos bares y restaurantes y
tranquilizaría a los clientes
la mayoría de gente me dice que si los
restaurantes volvieran a abrir no se
sentirían cómodos sin un pasaporte de
vacunas de opinión todo sabe esto no
salió club significaría estar en un área
cerrada con personas que no conocen
están preocupados by no me morí pero la
mayoría de los centros culturales están
en contra de la idea de reabrir y amos
lo que significa aquí el apoyo estatal
terminaría pero no tendríamos clientes
ya que muy pocas personas han recibido
la vacuna por lo que casi nadie podría
ir al cine o de compras no es viable y
es muy preocupante suisse éste se quitó
el pasaporte también plantearía un
enigma legal por los temores de que
pudiera infringir las libertades civiles
básicas no tienen que estar vacunado
pero si quieres ir a un restaurante al
cine o visitar un museo hay que
vacunarse entonces es tan bueno como
obligatorio el gobierno no ha descartado
definitivamente el pasaporte de vacunas
pero asegura que es demasiado pronto
para decidir